we finally have a Legend of Zelda movie
early the closest thing we have gotten
or will probably ever get to a Legend of
Zelda movie Kubo and the two strings
sounds like a band so Kubo is a
stop-motion animated film or otherwise
known as claymation although it's not
clays or just stop-motion 7 what it's
about is actually kind of tough it has
really thick mythology ultimately this
kid Kubo has to go on an adventure with
a Beatle man and a monkey and he has
things to do his destiny to fulfill is
great need to know because it's pretty
cool when a movie has adventure that's
cool when it has adventure with a cool
character that's cool also I was rootin
for kuba the entire time when he has
adventure with a cool character and good
supporting characters that's the great
bonus check on that evan has adventure
with a great character great supporting
characters and cool mythology and magic
everything you look for in a good
adventure movie that's pretty much kuba
seriously not only was the character
Kubo great let's talk about the
supporting characters Matthew
McConaughey plays beetle and Charlize
Theron plays monkey she is in fact a
monkey both work right and their own
waving monkey was take no get it
done I'm here to protect you Kubo so
stop messing around I know best beetle
was just as laid back Matthew
McConaughey radda radda right type and
they were great dynamic but I loved the
adventure I mean it's not always
excitement excitement excitement thrown
at you if at any point this movie has
the opportunity to sacrifice what might
be a crazy action sequence for some
heart it's going to take the heart and
unlike Captain Planet this is a time
where heart actually wins that's what I
loved about this movie had emotion ahead
of surprising amount of gravity and
weight to its meet those yeah let's talk
about the meet those two I got the
mythology in here it was just everything
that this movie built its world its
world that you see the world you don't
the spectral realm everything magic
origami everything is building around I
just I completely love I will say in a
couple parts though couple parts might
be too scary for kids I mean kid there
were a couple of kids crying in the back
I love hearing that I don't know why
it's just like it's a litmus test for me
if there's a kid's movie or an animated
film where that makes kids cry during a
scary scene I'm almost like nice this
movie went there and
that I gotta say this movie is more
geared towards adults I do think that
anybody will find enjoyment in this kids
teenagers adults older adults but all in
all it's geared towards adults more than
kids I mean when there are slow parts
where people are talking not boring
they're just hashing stuff out they're
talking they're giving gravity and
weight to the situation in the world and
the characters that's great but I feel
like adults will appreciate that more
than kids and then scary scene happens
among an action sequence you're like I
do adults will not cry in the theatre is
one of the movies I saw later in the
week because I have had a busy week and
I was actually really irritated that I
didn't get this review up earlier
because I might have been able to tell
more people to watch Kubo where the
movie falters is ultimately there are a
couple of pacing moments where I feel
like there could have been something
that better merged two points I feel
like a couple times this movie went from
A to C and I was like where's B right
there in the end guys Kubo is one of the
coolest adventures I have seen this year
it has a great lead character great
supporting characters great banter among
the supporting characters great
mythology great culture has a lot of
heart by the end of this film I was I
was tearing up man man tears they were
happening guys in the end Kubo hit me
right there right in the heartstrings I
will say Kubo is awesome tacular
all right guys so to bow have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more